introduced in Super Street Fighter 4  Juri is a sadistic Taekwondo expert with  a cybernetic eye  sheilo shadaloo for killing her parents  and wants nothing more than to see and  bison dead  juries v-skill is a challengeable wash  attack that kicks the opponent in the  back the charge can also be canceled  with a dash the trigger lesser chain had  normal attacks together both in and out  of the air it also removes the charge  restrictions on some of her special news  much like greedy juries bag heavy kick  is an excellent normal for confirming  into damage it hits twice the safe on  block links into a standing light kick  and is both special and Deitrick  accountable  her health and stun may be slightly  below average the jury more than makes  up for it we'll have flexible music her  trio of charge based specials in  particular are the key to LACMA her true  damage potential